in 2017 apple revolutionized the iphone  with their new iphone 10 packing an  edge-to-edge display in their brand new  face id system with the only compromise  being the notch but thankfully over the  past year we've been getting some very  convincing leaks and rumors from various  sources that apple will not only be  switching to a hole punch design for the  iphone 14 pro but they're also gonna  make it pill shaped apple was able to  merge the flood illuminator and the dot  projector into a single module they're  gonna take that single module and  they're gonna stick it under the display  leaving only the front camera the  infrared camera and potentially the  proximity sensor renders by shylesh  helped me out with some custom renders  and bam that's the iphone 14 pro or at  least what i believe is gonna look like  there's no sim card tray you have the  glass extending out the front and the  back and of course we have the new pill  shaped cut out